the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
you
so how many of you have exposure
taking any heat transfer classes here
it's about half of you
cool so can you start by telling me what
heat is
it sounds like pretty basic yeah okay
it's a form of energy what are the units
of that
and without heat transfer
what would our I guess that's pretty
self-explanatory just transferring Heat
what are the units of heat transfer
generally you're trying to figure out
how much energy is being transferred per
second so you can have a Joule per
second or watts yeah so what are what
are like what are three major modes of
heat transfer as well if do you remember
awesome
and help from people who haven't seen
this material before tell me if I'm
going through it too quickly when I
started talking about it but
can someone can okay can people explain
what the difference is between the three
types of heat transfer
what
yes okay
cool
and radiation
yeah
I think is more generally just heating
through electromagnetic waves but yeah
so that's kind of the three the three
sort of big modes of heat transfer you
have we'll be talking about convection
and conduction a lot more later when
we're doing say cooking and stoves
because that plays into that a lot more
like when you're putting a pot on a fire
like but we're dealing with solar solar
stuff we're gonna be dealing mostly with
radiation but while we're on the topic
of heat or while we're on the topic of
heat transfer I might as well give you
the equations for there the other two
but we'll start by talking about
radiation so when we're dealing with
when we're dealing with radiation we're
when we're dealing with radiation we're
thinking of objects giving off energy in
electromagnetic waves the only thing
that it really matters when you're
dealing with this is what the
temperature of the object is so you can
approximate things as or there's an
equation for it which is which is the
heat transfer from due to radiation is
the stefan-boltzmann constant times the
area of the surface area of the object
times the temperature to the fourth
which is an important equation to know
for convective heat transfer you have a
different equation but again like this
isn't that relevant so I'm going to move
on to talking to you guys about
about
so are different types of solar
technologies now so the first one we're
going to talk about is so this do you
guys have you do you think ok so you
have so dias
you have solar thermal so solar thermal
is when your there are different types
of technologies where you're using heat
from your using this heat from the
sunlight directly so you're using solar
radiation to heat things and there are
three different sorts of big ways you
can do this you can do use it for
cooking and drying you can use it for
heating of water and you can use it for
generating electricity and you also have
photovoltaics which we worked with last
time for generating electricity do you
so so does the way so districts is you
fill bottles with water and you close
the cap then you leave these bottles out
on a rooftop and you expose them to
sunlight for about six hours and you you
can store like I'm the UV light from the
Sun plus the heat from the Sun also
kills the pathogens and bacteria inside
the water if you remember do you guys
remember from last week when we were
built like playing with the bags
there was a sodus bag does that sound
familiar at all with the plastic sealer
yeah
why are you were you laughing
yeah so so so this is a really cool
technology it's an example of how you
can use solar energy to purify water
there are like there are other ways you
can use solar energy to purify water too
but this is supposed to be one of the
better ones so I guess we kind of jumped
ahead by showing you a really good so
does technology last week before talking
to you about so just as I was like a
technology but in most of the developing
world the companies that are promoting
sodus what they do is they tell people
to use 2-liter bottles which are
available in a lot of the developing
world and fill them with water and leave
them out on the rooftops can you guys
think of any ideas or any reasons why
this is not a good idea
or what's or what isn't the best okay
why isn't the best solution to using
this technology or best implementation
of this technology and why say a bag
would be better so what are some of the
problems with with a plastic bottle so
you have this plastic bottle it was kind
of like that yeah
whereas back was like
yeah I haven't seen that particular
issue before but that's a good point
what about in terms of transportation
how easy is it to get a plastic bottle
that's shaped like this what if I go if
I wanted to provide an entire community
with these how would I send it to them I
would have to like I would have to ship
a giant container with two-liter bottles
and they don't really pack well at all
right you need to feel like a crate of
two-liter bottles and it just seems
really silly to ship an empty container
or a container of empty water bottles in
places where they have to waiter bottles
it's a really good technology because I
mean if they're just taking existing
things that they already have and
they're using them repurposing them for
Abyss then it's great but otherwise it's
not it doesn't seem to make that much
sense to try to fly them in and that's
what some of like the companies that
we're really promoting so just heavily
in the beginning we're doing they were
trying to like ship two-liter bottles in
bulk to communities to get them to use
them can you guys think of any other
disadvantages to using using these water
bottles what about so how does how does
okay maybe I'll go a little bit more
into how the technology works so you
have your water bottle like this I guess
that's about how it looks
with your ear capped water bottle it's
filled with water like say this is all
water so what so what happens is you
have sunlight coming from here it's
heating up the water and he yes
so
yeah so because because water and your
plastic both absorbed some of the
sunlight you have you have a lot of it
being absorbed by this fluid and with
what they say is if you have like if
this depth is more than four inches that
so this is effectiveness is dropped by
maybe fifty percent I think is what they
say so yeah so that's another problem I
think I think of two-liter bottles right
about is about the right size so it's
not it's still Mike in the Ranger to the
right size so you're not gonna have to
over or you're not gonna have more than
four inches there but that's definitely
something to take into consideration
what about it what about places so what
about the cap and you guys think is why
the cap might be a problem
yeah that's exactly like one of the
biggest problems with so this with using
a water bottle it's just because the
region in this area where the cap is
just doesn't like doesn't I mean it's
opaque plastic so your UV rays are
getting most of them are getting blocked
by the plastic and so your bacteria
don't die it necessarily over there so
that's why that's why the bag that Sean
frame came up with the service bag that
you guys saw the other time they'd used
two one-way valves works a lot better
because the entire thing is transparent
and there were big rivers a lot of work
trying to be that people are trying to
do trying to redesign this into a better
system so like they looked at they
looked at the problems with the was
transportation with the 2-liter bottle
and then they came up with another blind
bag that was kind of like just a bag
that had a handle here and then it had
the same sort of like twist on cap over
here that it's two later bottle does
like that and then they made the back of
the black or the back of the bag black
so that it would heat up more which was
a pretty cool design but then we still
had problems with well for one having
having like expensive molded parts is
also really expensive because you and
you can't really fabricate that
everywhere like you can go into a
village and expect and try to create
something that looks like this or even
something that looks like this whereas
if you have a simple plastic sealer you
could make one of those soda spikes that
we were working on or that we saw last
week
does anyone has anyone not seen these
service bags from last week or have no
idea what I'm talking about okay and how
many of you have heard of sodas before
okay say yeah so this design sort of
went from this iteration to this
iteration and then Shawn Frey and he
came along and worked on it a little bit
and came up with the next iteration of
or came up with his technology which is
like a really really good technology in
terms of usage because I want you guys
to start thinking about these
technologies and how you would use them
to what's another problem but it's with
this you're supposed to take this you're
supposed to leave it out in the Sun for
six hours and then it or six hours to
two days depending on the weather
conditions and then it's supposed to
clean your water and you're supposed to
drink it yeah
no no you just you just take water right
and you leave it out of the Sun and the
UV rays from the Sun kill the bacteria
and it breaks down the bacteria any
container as long as it's clear that
usually transparent or solar
disinfection I should explain that yes
sir I guess so this is stands for solar
disinfection sir you're purifying water
just using sunlight it's a technique
so then they
water bottles are
last
federación I do definitely
so generally leaching from plastic is a
much like it's a problem it's on a much
smaller scale than having unsafe
drinking water and so if you have to
choose the trade-off between having some
plastic potentially leach into your
water and drink it and over like dozens
of years that might cause some health
problems versus having unsafe drinking
water like you would choose you would
definitely choose on safe or you
definitely choose the drinking using
sodas to drink your water but yeah that
is some of them like that is one of the
bigger concerns which is cool are there
any other questions about sodas
alright then I'm gonna go into solar
drying so solar drying is another
technology that is used in a lot of
places in the world and the idea is
basically that you you take fruits or
whatever and you you dry them so that
you can preserve them and the thing is
like a lot of in a lot of places you'll
have you'll have farmers for growing
something and they'll all have crops
that grow at the same time and so the
harvest and then they'll go take them to
the market and because there's an
overabundance of these fruits or
something people are getting their peak
they're not getting as much as the money
as they can for these for their fruits
because because there's way too much of
there's a way more supply than people
there's a demand for it so so and if
they don't have a very good way of
preserving food otherwise so they can't
like refrigerate these fruits so if they
don't if I don't keep them refrigerated
then they're just gonna spoil so it's
either sell at a low cost or don't get
anything for them and so there are food
preservation is a pretty big deal as
well and so you can use solar energy to
also dry fruits and this is a project
called fruits of the Nile that works in
Uganda were they deal with that and then
I'm gonna go to talking about solar
thermal panels for water heating I don't
know if you guys have seen these these
are taken from the US these pictures but
have you have any idea if you have
exposure to solar thermal okay so you're
basically what you're basically doing
here is you have well they're two types
of systems which I'll I guess are on the
next slide but so you have you have two
different types of systems but this is a
little bit more complicated than it
needs to be so basically the idea is
you're taking in sunlight
and using the sunlight your heating
water or some sort of fluid and so you
have sort of this container that's
shaped like this
we have tubes that have water or some
container or something running it
through it sunlight hits this container
heats up the water inside these tubes
and then you get at a new store the hot
water in a tank so that's a direct solar
thermal system there's also indirect
solar thermal systems or instead of now
instead of having your water being
heated directly you're you have a heat
exchanger here and then you have some
sort of fluid that goes through the
system and then you have your reservoir
or something and what's heating the
water is just like hot fluid like in the
heat exchangers what's heating the water
a heat exchanger is just something that
transfers heat from one thing to another
if you were wondering and so there's a
lot of solar thermal is way less
efficient than solar PV photovoltaics
but it's also significantly cheaper I
don't have numbers for you for that
issue but but you you know like you
don't want to think of solar thermal is
only being a small-scale technology
because there are large-scale
applications to fit as well this is sort
of like the smallest case you can think
of it would be like having one of these
for your household in like for your
household to heat water for showering or
something like that and then you have
larger scale versions of this too which
is
the loose project in the Mojave Desert
and it's the largest solar thermal
electric insulation in the world it has
350 mega watt peak output and didn't see
like this picture those are three people
standing next to it so the thing is
massive it's it's on the order of
kilometers yeah and the way this works
is it's similar to this except you have
you have your pipes that have your pipes
that have water in them but then you
have these concentrating troughs that
are focusing all of all of the sunlight
onto the pipes and so you get with the
way this normally works is you have this
technology versus you have you heat up
water to the point where it turns into
steam and then you have the
steam-powered turbine and then you
produce electricity using that
did you do research to help
ideally selected
to speak
what is this
our entire new generation
so Oh so these yeah these generate
electricity yeah that make sense
you have steam which powers a turbine
and that turbine generates electricity
and so you like not only do you have do
you have yeah they're like you're not
just taking you're not doing something
simple like heating water anymore
you could also using the same technology
but now you're generating electricity
from it and I thought I would throw this
and just for fun this was another cult I
like this is a project that I was
working on last year in Brazil and it's
a really low cost solar water heater but
the reason I threw this in was because
away a lot of these lower cost cheaper
ones work is they they work based off of
it their most - and so basically what
happens is when you have what happens is
in a system like this you'll have a
system like this is connected to a tank
and so water heats up in this and as
water heats up you mean you like if you
remember from I guess I guess you
learned this in middle school hot air
rises like things like that so hot water
Also Rises so you get you got a flow of
water towards the top of this thing so
what happens is if you connect this to a
reservoir you'll get and you basically
get a flow caused just by the
temperature differential in the water so
hot water will rise flow into this
reservoir and it'll get displaced by
cold water and so you you're regulating
the temperature and heating all of the
water consistently which is pretty cool
because with a system that based off of
the thermo siphon you don't need to
throw in a pump or something like that
to extract the water from your yes yeah
it's just you soon
but yeah so it's like it's just a
passive way of doing the same sort of
flow I'm gonna go into are there any
questions on any of what I've talked
about I know I did or like a really
really cursory job of heat transfer
earlier but that's because we're gonna
go more into it when we were talking
about photovoltaics but and more next
week when you're going into conductance
and convection for cooking but are there
any other questions that you guys have
about what we just talked about okay so
we're gonna move on to photovoltaics I'm
gonna try to explain to you how solar
cells work I got a lot of this
information was taken from this website
called PvE education it's actually used
to be called PV cd-rom which I thought
was pretty funny because it's a website
now okay so I guess it's been around for
a while how many of are you familiar
with this yeah okay it's a great
resource for a lot of information that
you might end question
it'll answer a lot of the questions you
have and it does a pretty good job of
keeping its level like basic enough for
you to understand plus being mathy
enough for you to actually understand
what's going on too if you're interested
in that so so let's start by say you
should you should go on that and read up
on more of it if you want if you have
time and you are inclined to learn more
about how photovoltaics all right but
anyway the temperature of the Sun does
anyone know what the temperature of the
Sun is about
a little bit's a little high that's a
little higher it's less them that's it's
about it's about 6,000 Kelvin 6,000
well so so to be fair when you when you
have the so you have the Sun and it's
kind of like that you have you have the
core where there's fusion going on and I
think the the core temperature is maybe
like 20 million Kelvin or something like
that so something like that it's
something ridiculously high I might be
off by an order or two of magnitude in
some directions but it's not really that
important but what happens is most of
that energy is blocked off by there like
this sort of dense hydrogen around here
and then you have the very like end of
you have the outer rim of the Sun which
is at about 6,000 Kelvin which is what's
radiating most of the heat to the earth
and so that's where we get all of our
energy from it's kind of cool to look at
a graph of what the energy of what the
irradiance looks like this is what this
is what wavelength so this is a weird
graph the red green and blue are three
different types of lighting and the
purple is what the Sun is so you can
ignore the other three but you should
look at the purple to see what
wavelength of light the signed outputs
that it's it's interesting because you
can see that this is also a on a log
scale so it's you can see that the bulk
of the light is in the visible spectrum
which is cool because yeah
but to and to measure how much energy is
being outputted by by sorry by the Sun
you can just integrate under this curve
to find out a bit to measure the entire
thing do you guys know what the energy
from a single photon is based off of the
wavelength to remember the equations for
that so you can calculate you can
calculate someone say yeah if it's
Planck's constant times C over lambda so
you have this you don't need to know
this equation but it'll give you a good
sense of how you can derive how much
energy is coming from a photon or a wave
so so this is Planck's constant this is
the speed of light and this is the
wavelength and so it's important from
this is that lower the lower the
wavelength the more energy you have
so yeah you your blue light is going to
have more energy than in your red light
does that make sense
cool so so you have this sea have your
son it's outputting so you have the son
what you're looking at is radiating a
bunch of electromagnetic waves in the
form of I guess photons to the earth
which is here what's and then we're
trying to look at what happens like if
we're trying to follow the path of this
radiation we can see that not all of it
reaches the earth or not all of it that
reaches the earth makes it to the
surface of the earth because a lot of it
is absorbed by our atmosphere and so
this is a kind of graphic that'll show
you where a lot of energy is lost or so
only only about 70% of it is actually
directed to the earth 3% is scattered to
space and 18% is absorbed by the
atmosphere now we're going to go into
how a solar cell works so yeah okay
so this is like also a little bit
complicated so you have a solar cell
which looks like this if you haven't
seen one before
they're super fragile we can pass them
around these are broken ones Evergreen
Solar was like was kind enough to donate
200 of these tests for this lab and for
our projects we'll be playing with them
and wiring them up today
so are you what happened yeah they're
they're super fragile you can see why
like it's one of the reasons why working
with solar cells is such a pain because
they're so easy to break like when
you're trying you have to solder them
together to make them work so it's kind
of difficult into that later so how do
they work so you basically have two
layers and your solar light in your
solar cell
as described in this drawing and what
happens this you have a photon coming in
and for one their their semiconductor so
you can tell me what a semiconductor is
okay yes
when you hits
like the basic family
that's correct yeah that's I did if you
understand that okay so so basically
happens is you have in a semiconductor
you have things in there pretty like
ordered patterns you'll have like
something like that and so they're all
that beli found in the slightest and so
what happens is they don't have free
electrons right now but you can get a
free electron from them if you excite
the electron with enough energy and so
if you have a photon coming in and has
the right amount of energy to excite an
electron out of one of these bonds then
the electron of valence electron or out
of the lattice the electron the electron
becomes excited and you then get in
electron hole pair and this is all a
gross simplification of how this works
because a lot of this is like I mean you
can't really just think of you can't you
can think of electrons as particles that
are moving across a circuit but that's
not actually how it works but for this
you're gonna like assume this
simplification makes sense to try to
like conceptually understand how it
works so what happens is you have the
lack of photon hitting this so you get
this electron hole pair and you can
think of a hole is where the electron
was before and so now there's this space
where this electron was and so it's kind
of positive area because because they're
like there's less electrons like there's
no electron there anymore so you can
think of it kind of like a bubble and a
fluid almost and so this electron wants
to go back into this bubble and this
bubble is free to move as well just like
the electron is free to move through
this structure now because they can't
rent it can go through it and so what
happens is if you but the thing is that
you're using two different types of
silicon and one of them is an n-type and
one of them is a p-type and the N and P
H stand for negative and positive and so
the other thing is you can you can dope
silicon
and what that does means you put
impurities in it and that creates a
permanent electric field inside the
silicon and so so one of your sides is
more positive and one of them is more
negative so when you create this when
you create this electron hole pair here
they're gonna want to be pulled towards
opposite directions just based off like
based off of what based off of drift and
so once they get pulled to either side
you can if you create a circuit and you
put a load on this thing then you can
have the electron flow through here and
go back into the holes here then it'll
close the circuit again and combine with
the yeah so that's that's a very like
simplified way of how photovoltaics work
work does that make sense to people are
there any questions about that
now the intouch would be the negative
the n-type is negative
it's true we could actually just watch
it
I had it open it
yeah anyway
so so we can
that's basically how photovoltaics work
you get yes this is sunlight at the
junction
I mean because you have like the holes
on the side creating the
the near the opposite
doesn't the light hit the middle I mean
that that that's what that was my
understanding
I don't I'm not sure I thought how I
understood I don't think I feel like so
the reason for the ABS like the
absorption coefficient of silicon is
really low so so you have like you have
a lot of different solar cells right do
you have any more facility and you have
like multi crystalline silicon and stuff
and the reason why you have like thin
film themselves as well but the reason
why silicon cells are so thick is
because the absorption coefficient is so
low that you basically need a thicker
area to be able to absorb most of the
the light I'm not answering your
question and what you thought you think
that and my understanding was that it
would hit the middle and filled with
forced electrons to go in one direction
which would then be used to then be
helped by an external circuit well
there's a few I like factors of play so
you have a so you have one side that's
more that has I can show you a video on
on how
I don't know this will work so this is
from this is from this PV cd-rom website
and so it's an animation saying how
things work and so if you have a if you
have a moderate field you have so you
have two things that work you have
diffusion and the thing is in diffusion
the way diffusion works is if you have a
lot of I mean it just if you have a lot
of holes on one side and electrons on
the other the electrons want to tend to
go to the side where there aren't
electrons and the holes want to go tend
to go to the side where there are holes
and so you have that but that's working
against the the positive and negative
factor of like or the positive and
negative charges of the two sides as
well so you have those two kind of
balancing each other out in some way so
really confused
so what you have
okay yeah so once you have a once you're
connecting this to a load you you're now
enabling the holes and electrons to
travel across this conductive region -
and so they're not only like now they're
not just diffusing and drifting through
here they're also like traveling through
does that not that's still not answering
your question my understanding was
that's where the electrons where I mean
that's where the Lightning and that's
where the electrons were ejected and
then it would ya pretty look pretty sure
that I'm pretty sure that like the light
excites alike are crates that electron
hole pairs anywhere inside the entire
but I can double-check with you at all
cool so now we're going to go into some
practical considerations for developing
world work and solar
yes
what exactly is great
years
I can also get back yeah
so let's look let's look at some of the
financial tools that are available in
order to finance a solar so you can do
the four sort of big ones are
microfinance a fee-for-service income
generation or smaller systems and then
so you have for microfinance you have
smaller payments over a longer period of
time for fee-for-service you have a
company that owns a PV system and a
household that pays the electric bill
for it for income generation which we
saw I think in the lighting lecture last
week we saw the how people were using
solar panels to generate income you use
a system to improve the income stream so
you can look at something like this
you'll have one person with a lot of
solar panels will charge a lot of
batteries and rent them out is
electricity and then for smaller systems
you can supply you can scale the
technology down so you're not using
giant solar panels anymore but you're
using smaller sort of panels to power
Lantern or something like that for
example yeah and so that was the bulk of
what I wanted to talk about today about
solar cells I guess one of the
interesting things about it to note
about them is that it's weird because
they're they're technologies that's very
much
there's a quote from Harish hande who is
the founder of SELCO that's solar is
expensive for the rich and affordable
for the poor if the rich who need
subsidies and it's sort of this weird
thing is electricity for the amount that
people need in the developing world for
like the amount like the amount of
energy that they need their solar is a
very cheap solution for that whereas the
amount of electricity that we're using
it like at the scales we're looking at
solar is a very expensive option
compared to other sorts of electricity
so it's it's pretty important like it's
pretty important to think about or it's
like important to think of solar is not
an expensive technology per se because
because I think in in the u.s. at least
we have that bias as solar being
expensive and Felco makes profit because
they sell all their solar panels without
subsidies at all so I thought that was
pretty cool
you